all right let's get reaction now from
capitol hill republican senator from
tennessee and member of the senate
housing and urban affairs foreign
relations and appropriations committees
senator bill hagerty now joins us live
from nashville senator thanks so much
for spending your saturday with us for a
little while i want to start with title
42 and this uh ruling obviously
it's going to stay for now but at some
point realistically title 42 is going to
go away i know that you and other
members of your party want a
vote in the senate on title 42 to keep
it in place do you think you can get
that support now
from the other side of the aisle now
that we've seen this ruling come down do
you think you can get that support
well all this ruling is is a stay of
execution we still have a massive crisis
at the southern border this past month
saw the greatest number of illegal
immigrants come into the country that
we've ever seen in my home state of
tennessee we still have each month more
overdoses and more deaths from fentanyl
coming across that border than we've
ever had before it gets worse by the
month the biden administration is doing
everything they can to transform america
and title 42 is the last tool left for
our border patrol agents to actually
push back again it's a public health
usage i think the biggest public health
crisis frankly is that that's from
overdoses that are being created here
again the biggest killer of young
americans between the ages of 18 and 45
right now in america
is overdose deaths you know the blind
administration will not acknowledge it
senator dhs secretary mayorkus has been
on the hill quite a few times now and
i know that several of members of your
party believe that the administration is
failing and its immigration policies but
majorcas and others would say that
congress isn't doing enough for
immigration reform are you willing to
work with your democratic colleagues on
the hill to come together and put
together some kind of immigration reform
package to deal with this in the long
term
i'm willing to work with the democrats
and only work with anybody to get this
problem fixed but no one on the democrat
side will step up i put forward
legislation to actually expand title 42
and to include
among the public health crises that was
trying to combat drug overdose deaths
and the concern of that i couldn't get a
single democrat to join me in that
conversation we're going to continue to
push on this but as you say congress is
ready to act at least on our side of the
aisle to make title 42 permanent but
also we need to put the migrant
protection protocols back in place that
was actually working biden won't even go
to the border and address this crisis
and it's really just crushing america
one last question on title 42 and
immigration before i want to get to
inflation as well
i went to mexico just last weekend to
the san diego tijuana border and saw
things on the ground first hand and what
i saw were was that there are places in
mexico that are that offer stability and
offer safety for some of these migrants
should
mexico be doing more to incentivize some
of these people coming from those
triangle countries should congress be
putting more pressure the administration
be putting more pressure on mexico to do
more
well that's exactly what president trump
did when he implemented the migrant
protection protocols he put a tremendous
amount of pressure on the mexican
government they actually began to patrol
the border again now that border has
been seeded to the cartels i think it's
going to be very difficult for mexico to
do anything without us putting pressure
on them but they should they should do a
lot more and i think what we'll see is
if we would go back to the policies that
were working we would have a tremendous
impact on reducing this crisis but
instead people are just piling up on the
other side of the border they are being
turned away under title 42 but the biden
administration keeps sending signals
that they're going to do away with it
again if they do away with it we're
going to see a tsunami of people coming
in it's a crisis that will turn into a
massive disaster and senator really
quickly on what everyone is talking
about right now which is gas prices if
we can pull up the prices on the screen
you can't go anywhere in this country
anymore and not pay more than four
dollars a gallon yet congress just
approved a 40 billion dollar aid package
to send to ukraine which got some
republican pushback including you you
voted no on that this week very
interestingly enough the new york times
editorial board wrote a piece urging the
president
to reconsider our investment in ukraine
or at least come up with a more detailed
plan an end game
and they write this as the war continues
mr biden should also make clear to
president vladimir zelinsky and his
people that there is a limit to how far
the united states and nato are willing
to go will go to confront russia and
limits to the arms money and political
support they can muster senator do you
believe that ukraine can win this war or
do we need to start coming up with some
kind of endgame a compromise perhaps
well ukraine can win the war and we need
to come up with a fully strategic
approach to this the best thing that we
could do would be actually in the war on
american energy here that would defund
vladimir putin's war machine that's what
we need to do first and foremost the 40
billion dollars that we're sending over
there right now that's the size of my
state of tennessee's entire annual
budget there have to be limits to this
you know the biden administration is
willing to spend on things like this
with very little oversight very little
details is involved in this there isn't
an end game in sight we should be
walking side by side marching side by
side with our colleagues in europe
they're not stepping up to this level
right now we're at parity with them but
with this 40 billion dollars we're
jumping way ahead of them forex what the
europeans are spending and they're more
proximate to the problem we need to be
bringing them along we need to be
looking at this holistically yeah we
need to be solving the energy crisis at
the same time and that would address
inflation here at home and i imagine as
gas prices continue to rise and we keep
seeing things like the baby formula
shortage happen americans will continue
to ask those questions senator thank you
so much for joining us on this saturday
have a great day
thank you very much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight